Human remains found in the debris of the titan
submersible recover before the atlantic there's
stay.
Investigators hope the cause of the catastrophic
implosion which killed all five people on
board.
CNN's Paula newton has more details.
>> U.S. Coast guard announced that it had
found what it presumed to be human remains
on the sea floor.
That would be from the submersible titan.
They recovered the remains.
Saying that the medical professionals will
conduct a formal analysis.
Of the presumed human remains.
And of course the family and friends of those
five passengers who died on the titan will
be completed by this but also feel again profound
grief.
Given what the U.S. Coast guard says was an
implosion of the titan.
Some original.
What is also happening now is that on Wednesday,
the horizon
[1:13:27 AM]
that on Wednesday, the horizon arctic retrieved
debris.
In fact large pieces of debris.
They say they have finished their work out
there.
At the site of the titanic wreck.
And what is extraordinary here is that they
did in fact recover large pieces of the debris.
You could see the two who.
I had a good chunk of the passenger frame.
Again that issue here is the carbon fiber
material.
Used to hold the passengers.
Used in this kind of deep sea exploration.
U.S. Coast guard says they will begin to examine
all but.
And again there are many investigations underway.
Including here in Canada.
The investigation expected to take well very.
Former assistant secretary security now teaches
at Harvard university.
Good to see you.
>> Good to see you.
Right now, it is still not known how much
the titan
[1:14:27 AM]
known how much the titan actually, cause the
U.S. Government has apparently working on
that number, but Canada sent more assets into
the search, France was involved as well.
As an indication of the cost, is part of a
report from the Washington post.
Three c-17 cargo planes filled with equipment
from Buffalo to staging points in Newfoundland.
Those flights cost an estimated $491,000 round
trip.
So, you, know that would seem to be a tiny
fraction of the cost here.
So in terms of resources come into the search,
how much it is going to end up costing at
the end of the day.
What is your assessment?
>> It is going to be much more expensive than
the low numbers around million that we initially
heard, you just think of man or woman, power
tonight, of essentially a weeklong effort,
you are going to get large numbers.
And, this question of the magnitude of the
search and rescue, it's different I. Want
to make clear, it is different than should
there have been a rescue.
Absolutely, and international conventions,
we honor
[1:15:28 AM]
conventions, we honor international search
and rescue conventions, every country has
an obligation to help a vessel that is under
the stress.
So, for some period of, time there might have
been an assumption that they could have either
survived, or that the submarine was floating
and they could just find it, and save people.
Essentially, overtime, though that became
clear it was not the fact, and the magnitude
of the resources that went to an incident
that we call a disaster management low probability,
and essential low consequence, raises a concern
that those resources were spent because not
because of the sort of rescue, but because
of who was in it, and the public pressure
to do something.
>> Well, Pentagon spokesman -- who was asked
about the cost of the titans search last,
week here's what he said.
>> When it comes to things like operating
aircraft, those come
[1:16:30 AM]
operating aircraft, those come from appropriated
funds which are already budgeted so, those
are hours that already have been paid.
>> You, know the cost may have alstill had
to come from somewhere, just because it's
in the, budget doesn't mean us free.
>> Exactly.
Look, I mean, an expenditure of funds in one
place is going to take away eventually funds
from another place.
So, either we should own up to the amount
that was spent, and have a reason for why
that much money was spent, or begin to have
an honest discussion about risk, and probability,
and if you necessitate to deploy our search
and rescue resources, whether it is a submarine,
or a hold out on an island who won't evacuate
during a hurricane, or hikers who are careless
and threatened force responders because they
have to be saved, all of those are hard questions.
But they are one of the disaster management
community is asking right now, because I think
we have -- one has to suspected this quite
[1:17:31 AM]
one has to suspected this quite high.
>> And, again just distressed, this is not
about you know not helping people who are
in distress, but what makes this contrast
so great, is that while the world was fixated
on the search for the titans summer supple,
and five very wealthy people in their, the
New York Times had this headline, five death
at sea grip the, world hundreds of others
got a shrug.
And those others were the 750 migrants who
died when a boat capsized in Greece.
And a point lost on former president Barack
Obama.
Here he is.
>> Right now we have 24-hour coverage, and
I understand it a this submarine, the submersible,
at the same time right here in just off the
coast of Greece, we have 700 people dead.
>> What makes it even worse is that they're
Greek recruits guard did not offer -- until
it was way too late, and it comes down really
to a question of priorities.
[1:18:32 AM]
question of priorities.
Right?
>> It does, and what the creek coast guard
did was not pursue to their own obligations,
moral, obligations but also to all coast guard
are, under which is, if a vessel is in distress,
you do not ask questions, it does not matter
what they were doing, or where they were going,
or whether it was lawful or, not it is a community
of response efforts that all agree that a
ship under distress should be saved, as you,
said it does not get to the magnitude, and
I think what the submarine with the titan,
we conflated high interest with high consequence.
In other, words this idea that the submarine
had a bigger story then unfortunately people
-- the world, we can see why it had billionaires,
the titanic, and all of our fears of getting
caught somewhere with the consciousness of
death, I get it, but it does not explain the
amount of resources that were
[1:19:33 AM]
amount of resources that were spent to find
a vessel that even if had been found, it was
not at all clear how we were going to get
it to surface.
>> And again, obviously this is a tragic accident,
very sad for